I finished the last video touching on
the stimulus plan and whether it's going
to be big enough and what its intent was
that was a little hand wavy about things
like savings in GDP and I thought it
would actually be good to get a little
bit more particular just so you know
that you know that this isn't just you
know me making up things so a good place
to start is just to think about
disposable income and people talk about
it without ever giving you a good
definition it's important to understand
what disposable income is so this box
right here is GDP so it's all the goods
and services essentially all of the
income that we produce the disposable
income is essentially the amount that
ends up in the hands of people so the US
GDP I don't know the exact number is
it's on the order of I think it's like
fifteen trillion dollars whoops it's on
the order of 15 trillion dollars and so
some of that money goes to taxes I don't
know maybe 30 let's just say four
trillion dollars of it let's say three
trillion dollars ends up in taxes and
these are round numbers but it gives you
a sense of the makeup then maybe and
about another one trillion is saved by
businesses so let's say that I'm
Microsoft and I make a billion dollars
this year Microsoft makes a lot more
than that but I make a billion dollars
and I just keep it in a bank account
owned by Microsoft I don't give it to my
employees I don't dividend it out to the
shareholders I just keep that so
corporate savings let's say it's another
trillion dollars these are roundabout
numbers and then everything leftover is
essentially disposable income I'm making
some simplifications there but
everything left over is just full income
and the idea is is what is in the hands
of households after paying their taxes
disposable income that check that you
get after your taxes and everything else
is taken out of your paycheck that money
that is disposable income to you so the
interesting thing is where this
disposable income has been going over
the last many many years so this chart
right here actually let me let me go
down a little bit so this right here
this chart is a plot of the percentage
of disposable income saved since 1960
and got this off of the Bloomberg
terminal again and just so you get a
good reference point let me draw the
line for 10% because I kind of view that
as a reference point that's 10% personal
savings actually you could go back even
further than this and you can see from
1960s all the way until the early 80s
the go-go 80s people were saving about
10% of their disposable income of what
they got on that paycheck after paying
taxes they were keeping about 10% of it
putting in the bank and of course that
would later be used for investment and
things like that but then starting in
the early 80s right around let's see
it's about 1984 see that people started
saving less and less money all the way
to the extreme circumstance to 2007
where you saved where on average people
didn't save money where you know maybe I
saved $5 but someone else borrowed $5 so
on average we didn't save money actually
we went slightly negative and all of
this and this is kind of my claim and it
can be borne out if you look at other
charts in terms of the amount of credit
we took on is because we took on credit
I guess there's two things you could
talk about we took on credit and we
started having what I called perceived
savings right if I buy a share of IBM a
lot of people say oh I saved I saved my
money I bought you know I'm invested in
the stock market but when I bought a
share of IBM unless that dollar I paid
for the share goes to IBM to build new
factories if it and that's very seldom
time most of the time that dollar I gave
to Ivy to buy that IBM shares just goes
to a guy who sold an IBM share so
there's no net investment it's only
investment it's only savings when that
dollar is actually goes to invest in
some way build a new factory or build a
new product or something so I think you
had more and more people thinking that
they were saving when they weren't maybe
thinking that they were saving is their
home equity and their house grew or as
their stock market portfolio went up but
there wasn't actual aggregate savings
going on and is in fact if anything they
were borrowing against those things
especially home equity and the average
saving rate went down and down and down
so now we're here in 2007 and maybe you
could say you know 2008 where let's say
that this is the capacity
because we should probably talk about
world capacity because so much of what
we consume really does come from
overseas but this is kind of the
capacity serving the US and let's say
going into 2007 this was demand supply
and demand was let's say pretty evenly
matched right and if we go to that top
up here you see that we weren't it like
kind of a you know we were at like 80%
utilization which isn't crazy so if
anything you could say that we had you
know demand was maybe right around here
but that's a good level you want to be
at around 80% utilization that's the
rate of which you don't have
hyperinflation and you bet you're
utilizing things quite well now all of a
sudden the credit crisis hits and all of
this credit disappears and I'd make the
argument that the only thing that
enabled us to not save this money is
more and more access to cheap credit
every time we went through a recession
and from the mid 80s onwards the
government solution was to make
financing easier the Fed would lower
interest rates we would pump more and
more money into Fannie and Freddie Mac
we would lower standards on what it took
to get a mortgage we would create
incentives for securitization we would
look the other way when Bear Stearns is
creating collateralized debt obligations
or AIG is writing credit default swaps
and all of that enabled financing right
until we get to this point right here
where everything everything everything
starts blowing up so you essentially
have for savings when people can't
borrow anymore the savings rate is going
to have to go to 10% because most of
this is just from people taking on more
credit there were as a group of people
who are probably all read always saving
at 10% of their disposable income but
they had another group of people who are
more than offsetting that by taking
credit
now that the credit crisis hits you're
going to see the savings rate and you
already see it here with this blip right
there the savings rate is going to go
back up to 10% of disposable income
now if the savings rate goes back to 10%
of disposable income that amount of
money that 10% of disposable income this
gap is 10% of disposable income that
cannot be used for consumption right and
let's think about how large of amount
that is right now u.s. disposable income
if I were to draw disposable income this
number right here I just looked it up
it's around ten point seven trillion
dollars let's just say 11 trillion
dollar
for roundabout so this 10% of disposable
income that we're talking about this gap
between kind of the normal environment
and what people what the environment
that was enabled from super easy credit
that's 10% of disposal income 10% of 11
trillion is 1.1 trillion dollars per
year of demand that will go away that's
per year so all of a sudden you're going
to have a gap where this was the demand
before and now the demand is going to
drop to here and all of this 1.1
trillion of demand is going to disappear
because the credit isn't because credit
is now not available and then you do get
a situation where you might hit a low
capacity utilization and unfortunately
the capacity utilization numbers don't
go back to the Great Depression and we
could probably get a sense of at what
point does a deflationary spiral really
get triggered but because at one point
one trillion dollars in demand
disappears you're going to see this
orange line just drop lower and lower in
terms of capacity utilization and that's
going to drive prices down and what
Obama and the Fed and everyone else is
trying to do is to try to make up this
gap now everyone else can't borrow money
companies can't borrow money homeowners
can't borrow money but the government
can borrow money because people are
willing to finance it
or at the bare minimum the feds willing
to finance the government and so the gut
the government wants to come in and take
up the slack with this demand and spend
the money themselves with the stimulus
now we just talked about what's the
magnitude of this demand shock it's 1.1
trillion dollars per year right 1.1
trillion while the stimulus plan is you
know on the order of a trillion dollars
and that trillion dollars isn't per year
although I have a vague feeling that we
will see more of them coming down the
pipeline this trillion this stimulus
plan that just passed this is expected
to be Pat spent over the next few years
so in terms of demand created over the
next few years it's going to be I don't
know several hundred billion per year so
it's going to be anywhere near or large
enough to make up for this demand shock
to make up for that demand shock so
we're still going to have low capacity
utilization so so the people who argue
that you know this these stimulus plans
are going to create a hyperinflation I
disagree with that at least in the near
term
because in the near term it's nowhere
near large enough to really soak up all
of the extra capacity we have in the
system and if anything it's going to
soak up different capacity so the
stimulus plan it might create
inflationary light conditions in certain
markets within where the stimulus plan
is really focused but other areas where
you used to have demand but the stimulus
plan doesn't touch like $50 spatulas
from William Sonoma or granite
countertops that area is going to
continue to see deflation and I would
say net net since the stimulus is
actually so small even though we're
talking about trillion dollars relative
to the amount of demand destruction
destroyed per year we'll probably still
have deflation and for anyone who's
paying close attention to it and I am
because you know I I care about these
things the best thing to keep a lookout
for to know when to kind of start
running to gold maybe or being super
worried about inflation is if you see
this utilization number creep back up
into the 80% range and you know at least
over the last 40 years that's been the
best leading indicator to say when are
we when are we going to have inflation
and for all those gold bugs out there
who are you know who who insist that all
of the hyperinflation or the potential
hyperinflation is caused by our not
being on the gold standard I just want
to point out that you can very easily
have you know we went off of Bretton
Woods and completely went to a fiat
currency in 73
that's right around let's see 69 it's
right around here but our worst
inflation bouts were actually while we
were on the gold standard and that's
because we had very high capacity
ization this is the war period what
happens during a war you run your
factories all out you run your farms all
out to feed the troops of factories
instead of building cars build planes
and everyone was working wages go up
everything goes up and you have
inflation right and a lot of people say
that oh you know the war was was the
solution of the Great Depression and it
is true and that it got us out of that
deflationary that negative deflation
airy stuff viral that I talked about in
that last video and it did it by
creating an unbelievable amount of
inflation and then after the war you
could argue you know what allowed I
don't have GDP here but the GDP US GDP
really did do well in the post-war
period and it wasn't the war
say although the war kind of did take us
out of the deflationary spiral it was it
was so you know after the war you had
all of this capacity after World War two
she had all this capacity that was used
being used up by the war then all of a
sudden the war ends and you're like what
we don't have to build planes anymore we
don't have to feed the troops anymore
and now we have all these unemployed
troops who come back home what are we
going to do with them right you would
say maybe capacity utilization would
come back down there
but what a lot of people don't talk
about is the rest of the industrial
world's capacity was blown to
smithereens the at that point in time
the u.s. was a smaller part of GDP and
the other major players were Germany
Western Europe and Japan and all of
these guys in the u.s. we didn't have
any factories bombed all of the wall the
entire war took place in these areas and
whenever people go on bombing raids the
ideal thing that they want to bomb is
factories so what you had in the
post-war period is you had all of these
countries had their capacity blown to
smithereens the u.s. was essentially the
only person left with any capacity and
so all the demand from the rest of the
world picked up the slack in the u.s.
capacity and that's why even though
there was a demand shock in the US after
that you had demand from what you also
had a supply shock from the war where
you had all of this capacity that was
blown to smithereens in this situation
that we are now we have a major demand
shock right financing just disappears
and the savings rates going to skyrocket
because people can't borrow anymore but
there's no counteracting supply shock
right supply of of really you know
factories making widgets and all the
rest is staying the same so the Obama
administration they're trying to create
a stimulus to stop some of this up but
it's not going to be enough and my only
fear is with all of the printing money
and all that goes is once we go to a
situation once we do get back to the 80%
capacity utilization once we do go back
here how quickly they can unwind all of
this printing press money and all of the
stimulus plan because that's going to be
the key because if we do get to 80%
capacity utilization or we start pushing
up there and we continue to run the
printing press because that's what
essentially governments incentive is to
do because they always feel better when
we're flush with money then and only
then you might see a hyperinflation
scenario but I don't see that at least
the next few years